don't get me laughs I mean it's funny  laughter yes to try reading a map yeah  Alan try reading anything ever yes to  try not being such a dumb nerd are we  doing this yeah Alan try not eating  every Arby's sandwich ever made yes do  why don't you try having an American  life yeah Alan try taking a bath once  every six years  joke's on you I had one two weeks ago  joke's on you my wife's American run  upstairs and grab a pair of sweatpants  for Alan here this is a sweat one  upstairs and grab a pair of sweatpants  for Alan here hello 44 poorly run  upstairs and grab a pair of sweatpants  for Alan here no allergic the dial on  the cotton-blend will do make sure  they're not made out of rayon cuz that  chain wonder my undercarriage your if  you'll face me so I do your butt think  I'll be in the limo okay tiger no hard  feelings